[Música]
rusia amenazó con bombardear nuevos
objetivos en ucrania y eeuu le da aquí
esa artillería de largo alcance según
dijo el presidente vladimir putin hoy
las tropas de moscú atacaron la capital
por primera vez desde el 28 de abril el
mandatario por lo civil se les volvió a
salir de la región de guía
la reina isabel segunda apareció
sorpresivamente en el palacio de
buckingham el cuarto y último día del
jubileo después de no ir a la mayoría de
los eventos de la celebración de sus 70
años en el trono la monarca dice estar
comprometida a servir ampliamos desde el
hombres
al menos 50 personas murieron en un
tiroteo dentro de una iglesia católica
en nigeria
los reportes clínicos afirman que la
mayoría de los fallecidos eran mujeres y
niños aunque se desconocen las causas
del ataque el gobernador regional afirmó
que dedicarán todos los recursos para
investigar
bienvenidos a las noticias aquí en
france24 yo soy maría clara calle y
gracias por estar con nosotros empezamos
con la actualidad de la guerra el
presidente ruso vladimir putin advirtió
que atacaría objetivos que hasta ahora
no ha bombardeado estos y eeuu le
entregan misiles de largo alcance a los
ucranianos su anuncio llega días después
de que la casa blanca- prometiera 700
millones de dólares en asistencia de
seguridad que incluye misiles de
precisión rusia también señaló que este
domingo destruyeron tanques donados
desde el extranjero y además hubo
bombardeos contra kiev los primeros que
se registran desde el 28 de abril cuando
atacaron en medio de la visita del
secretario de la onu antonio guterres
los ucranianos por su parte afirman que
los cohetes de este domingo fueron
lanzados desde el mar caspio y que uno
de los misiles voló muy bajo sobre la
segunda planta nuclear más grande del
país escuchamos lo que dijo putin
si se van a suministrar misiles de mayor
alcance sacaremos ciertas conclusiones y
utilizaremos nuestros propios medios de
destrucción y tenemos suficientes
a los objetivos que aún no hemos
alcanzado para el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr se le es que viajó a sap
orilla para agradecerles a los
combatientes de la región es la segunda
vez que el mandatario sale de kiev para
ir al frente de batalla y es que hace
una semana visito jarquín mientras tanto
los ucranianos lograron una victoria
parcial pero significativa en el este
autoridades locales aseguran que ya
controlan la mitad de severodonezk una
de las dos ciudades que faltan para que
los rusos se apoderen de toda la región
de lugansk veamos
es un potencial premio de consolación
aunque difícil de ganar 'rusia redobló
esfuerzos para acabar con los últimos
focos de resistencia en el donbass sus
fuerzas se enfrentaron a los soldados
ucranianos en las calles de las ciudades
estratégicas de severos nietes y
leasings
en general la situación es difícil ahora
aseveró don y es que es una mera
concentración de acciones de combate
entendemos que el ejército ruso está
lanzando todas sus fuerzas y reservas
las autoridades locales afirman que han
volado los puentes de los alrededores
para cortar las líneas de suministro de
ucrania pero aseguran que a pesar de
ello el ejército logró recapturar partes
de severodonezk pero rusia dice que las
fuerzas ucranianas se están retirando
también hubo ataques con misiles en la
ciudad de soledad en el donbass y un
aeródromo cerca de jarquín y el
ministerio de defensa ruso dijo que
habían derribado un avión de transporte
militar ucraniano cerca de deza mientras
los intensos combates tenían lugar una
fuerte reacción desde kiev tras el
pedido del presidente francés emmanuel
marco el viernes para no humillar a
rusia
las terribles consecuencias de esta
guerra pueden detenerse en cualquier
momento el ejército ruso puede dejar de
quemar iglesias el ejército ruso puede
dejar de destruir ciudades el ejército
ruso puede dejar de matar niños si una
persona de moscú simplemente da esa
orden y el hecho de que todavía no haya
esa orden es obviamente una humillación
para todo el mundo
mccomb es uno de los pocos líderes
occidentales que ha intentado
repetidamente dialogar con el presidente
ruso a raíz de su creencia de que
francia puede desempeñar un papel
mediador en el conflicto cambiamos de
noticia en una sorpresiva aparición la
reina isabel segunda saludo desde el
balcón del palacio de buckingham así se
roba el cuarto y último día del jubileo
la celebración con la que se conmemoran
sus 70 años al frente del trono reino
unido- no esperaba a ver a la reina pues
por sus quebrantos de salud no fue a la
mayoría de los eventos la monarca emitió
luego un comunicado en el que se excusó
por su ausencia y así le agradeció a los
británicos
si bien no asistí a todos los eventos en
persona mi corazón ha estado con todos
ustedes y sigo comprometida a servirles
con lo mejor de mi capacidad apoyada por
mi familia a propósito del jubileo
previamente desde londres nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido nos dio los
detalles del cuarto y último día de
celebraciones
con un carnaval de música de bailes que
duró más
colorido recorrido por de los 70 años
del reinado de isabel segunda que es
protagonista indiscutible de nuestra
historia protagonista desde el gran
imperio británico a lo que se conoce hoy
como la commonwealth concluyó este
último día de celebraciones del jubileo
de platino que marca los 70 años de
isabel segunda en el trono fueron días
vibrantes de la celebración por supuesto
la gente estaba a la espera de volver a
ver a la reina que apareció únicamente
en el primer día para él
los 96 años de vida en la ceremonia
militar ya era que se llama trooping the
colour pero la reina sabía que las
multitudes que han viajado incluso desde
diferentes partes del mundo para
presenciar este momento histórico
querían verla así que la reina salió
unos minutos
nuevamente
el balcón del palacio de buckingham para
saludar a quienes vinieron a acompañarla
en este día tan especial lo hizo con
gran parte de la línea de sucesión al
trono británico la acompañaron su hijo
carlos el príncipe william su nieto y su
bisnieto del príncipe george que son los
tres futuros monarcas y es la manera muy
sutil de la reina isabel de decirle al
público este es el futuro de la
monarquía prepárense estos son los
futuros reyes por supuesto la el festejo
se extendió hoy a las comunidades a los
diferentes barrios del país con grandes
eventos almuerzos colectivos porque la
celebración no quería ser únicamente en
londres con la familia real sino un
motivo
entre comunidades entre vecinos y entre
familias
en noticias del continente americano la
policía de filadelfia en eeuu reveló
nuevos detalles del tiroteo masivo que
hubo en una zona de bares y que dejó
tres muertos y 12 heridos las
autoridades dicen que dos individuos
discutieron y comenzaron a dispararse
agentes de policía que estaban en el
lugar respondieron hiriendo a uno de los
atacantes esa persona huyó y ahora
ofrecen 20 mil dólares por quien de
información de su paradero
el de filadelfia es uno de los múltiples
tiroteos masivos que ha habido en las
últimas 24 horas en eeuu en chattanooga
tennessee tres personas murieron y 14
fueron heridas en una balacera en un
club nocturno y en phoenix arizona una
adolescente falleció y ocho personas
resultaron lesionadas en un centro
comercial escuchemos lo que dijo la
policía de filadelfia
los uniformados observaron a varios
civiles con heridos de bala tirados en
la acera y en la calle los oficiales en
el lugar comenzaron a brindar primeros
auxilios a los heridos observaron a un
hombre desconocido en la esquina
suroeste de salud y américa construir
disparando una pistola contra una gran
multitud en la cuadra 400 del south
street desde aproximadamente media
cuadra de distancia
fue un acto horrendo e impensable que
sucedió en un lugar de reunión local y
turístico muy popular y que cobró la
vida de tres personas e hirió a otras
doce y el presidente de perú pedro
castillo fue llamado a declarar en una
investigación fiscal que tiene en contra
por presunta corrupción la fiscalía
peruana sitúa el mandatario para el 13
de junio casi yo puede acudir al
despacho fiscal o rendir testimonio
desde el palacio de gobierno el ente
investigador está indagando desde abril
las denuncias de irregularidades en la
construcción del puente tarata en la
amazonía peruana la fiscalía considera
que existió una organización criminal
ligada al actual ejecutivo de castillo
pero el presidente lo niega
al menos 50 personas murieron en un
tiroteo dentro de una iglesia en nigeria
asaltantes entraron con armas y
detonaron explosivos en la capilla
católica de san francisco mientras los
fieles celebraban el domingo de
pentecostés el hecho ocurrió en el
pueblo de hongo en el suroeste del país
una zona en la que los ataques son poco
frecuentes pues la violencia de los
islamistas radicales y de las bandas
armadas se concentra en el noreste un
representante de la cámara legislativa
inferior de nigeria afirmó que el
sacerdote fue secuestrado todavía no se
sabe quiénes fueron los autores pero el
gobernador estatal de on2 se comprometió
a designar todos los recursos necesarios
para dar con los responsables
este es un desarrollo inesperado estoy
sorprendido sin embargo dedicaremos
todos los recursos disponibles para
cazar a estos agresores y hacerlos pagar
nunca nos inclinaremos ante las
maquinaciones de elementos despiadados
en nuestra resolución de librar a
nuestro estado de criminales y hoy se
celebra el día mundial del medioambiente
la onu alertó sobre las consecuencias de
un planeta degradado esto para la salud
de los seres humanos ni en su calidad de
vida al mismo tiempo recordó los efectos
devastadores que tiene la crisis
climática sobre la fauna y la flora con
más de un millón de especies en peligro
de extinción el informe desde manuel a
cano
tres emergencias climáticas y una sola
tierra el calentamiento global la
pérdida de especies y la contaminación
acechan al planeta en el día mundial del
medioambiente la onu recalca que el 67
por ciento de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero están asociadas a
nuestro estilo de vida uno que
contribuye a que el planeta se caliente
a un ritmo demasiado rápido para que las
personas y la naturaleza se adapten un
medioambiente degradado que tiene
consecuencias en nuestra salud
la contaminación es responsable de unos
9 millones de muertes prematuras cada
año y según the lancet en 2019 causó una
de cada 6 muertes en el mundo esto es
más que las cifras anuales de muertes
debido a la guerra las drogas y el
alcohol otra alarma las zonas de peligro
climático cerca del 50% de la población
mundial vive en esos lugares donde tiene
15 veces más probabilidades de morir a
causa de los impactos climáticos y según
la onu para 2050 más de 200 millones de
personas cada año correrán el riesgo de
ser desplazadas debido a la alteración
del clima la fauna y la flora también
son las grandes afectadas más de un
millón de especies de plantas y de
animales corren el riesgo de
unos datos que alarman y un objetivo
mundial que sale a relucir el de limitar
el calentamiento global a 15 grados
centígrados para alcanzarlo la onu
asegura que debemos reducir a la mitad
las emisiones anuales de gases de efecto
invernadero para 2030 pasamos a asia en
bangladesh hubo un incendio en un
complejo industrial que causó al menos
49 muertos y dejó más de 200 heridos las
llamas empezaron en un depósito de
contenedores que portaban productos
químicos el informe es de luís muñoz
los esfuerzos se centran en las labores
de rescate
también en la extinción del fuego
la tragedia ocurrió en cita cuna cerca
de chittagong en el sureste de
bangladesh
mientras los hospitales están saturados
y los locales buscan señales de vida de
los suyos
anoche hablé con mi hermano diez minutos
antes del accidente no hemos tenido
contacto con él desde entonces no
sabemos nada sobre su condición o
paradero todavía verdad el incendio se
produjo en la noche del sábado en un
depósito de contenedores en una empresa
que cuenta con participación de una
corporación de países bajos tras el
fuego vinieron múltiples explosiones
decenas de personas han muerto y
centenares están heridas la causa real
detrás del incidente se revelará cuando
se investigue no debo hacer una
evaluación basada en conjeturas hasta
donde sé la oficina del comisionado
adjunto formó un comité de investigación
el cuerpo de bomberos debe haber
iniciado una investigación por separado
o lo hará se trata de una nueva tragedia
en un país que destaca por el pobre
historial de seguridad industrial pese a
ser el segundo exportador textil del
mundo las regulaciones son laxas y los
índices de corrupción altos por lo que
los bangladesíes se acostumbraron a este
tipo de incidentes
ya cerraron los colegios electorales en
kazajistán donde este domingo se votó un
referendo para cambiar la constitución y
las encuestas de boca de urna muestran
que sería aprobado la reforma
constitucional es promovida por el
presidente casi y omar toca jeff aunque
permitiría descentralizar la toma de
decisiones en otros aspectos fortalece
el poder presidencial pues el mandatario
conservaría las facultades para nombrar
jueces y gobernadores regionales y para
disolver el parlamento otro de los
grandes cambios es que le quitaría el ex
presidente nursultán nazarbáyev su
estatus de líder nacional que le da
privilegios de por vida los resultados
del referéndum se conocerían mañana
y terminamos con la marcha del orgullo
lgtb en tailandia la primera que ha
habido en la capital van gogh en 16 años
en todo este tiempo no se había
realizado por problemas de financiación
y por la inestabilidad política que
incluye dos golpes de estado en 2006 y
2014 los organizadores señalaron que
este año el desfile servirá para
celebrar la diversidad aunque advierten
que el país todavía está lejos de lograr
la igualdad de género
así nos despedimos y los invitamos a que
sigan conectados con nosotros
[Música]